all right and we are live welcome to the
iron Lords podcast episode number 92 and
it's another glorious Sunday we are back
at the roundtable on the Lord's Day
final episode of 2018 and I'm extremely
excited about our special guest we've
got Kingdom Hearts 3 I can switch pro
news discord vs. epic versus steam ashen
multi player and spider-man DLC to
discuss so we gonna get right into it I
want to introduce a lord who is not only
a great friend to the realm but in my
opinion is the personification of pure
entertainment positive energy and
infectious humor not only is this Lord
synonymous with the PlayStation brand he
embodies the essence of a true gamer
with fantastic news articles and
hilarious YouTube videos introducing the
creator and host of the PlayStation
broadcast and the editor-in-chief of the
PlayStation brahs calm the Lord of all
things Sony true family man and the Lord
you don't want dominating your fantasy
football league greatness has arrived
and it's finally making his debut into
the realm of the Lord's mom made nor
PlayStation brah how you doing sir
greetings iron Lords PlayStation brah I
have descended from greatness mountain
to grace my presence to you today I
bring with me ps4 exclusives PS VR games
of the year game of the award game the
year horizon zero dawn I bring with me
psvr greatness yes sin again I can't
bring with me Pearson name change until
we have the greatness but it's still
lacking a little bit and I apologize for
the pain so much
my Genki engineers can do I'm honored to
be here finally I'm sorry it took you
know six months but a took a better late
than never
exactly it took a minute but we got
there but we got there absolute pleasure
to have you in the room you are a lord
at what you do had the pleasure of
chilling and III with this fantastic
time fantastic sense we glad to be
fantastic memories made many have slowly
already know another way cog that that
introduced introduction was amazing you
sir only the best for the Lord's I was
I'm like I'm flattered man that was a a
plus plus plus
New Delhi already built so you know he
got the Four Horsemen of gaming those
original Lords in the realm here at the
round table
my co-host with the co most my brother
from another mother
the difficult game Conqueror and the
house of this young pulse mom me
lordy Lord attic you get the bike
situation coid so we gonna keep it
pushing and of course we both technical
gaming Lord the solo gamer who lives for
the single player selfish experience and
also the sastra Thomas mister offline
profile Illuminati and Laura patreon of
the iron baked mommy
Lord sovereign are you doing sir I'm
doing good man glad to be here I'm
awaiting energy don't need to 5-hour
energy today ready to go glad to have
the PlayStation raw play
I have to say man your name is the
favorite it makes my favorite name to
say during the patreon the PlayStation
brah you guys support me I got so the
look back would you be playing so so
yeah a little bit of gaming this week
finally a little bit of something still
haven't gotten back to red day but I did
try some of the new stuff it's been in
the bushes for like a damn month bro I
haven't I haven't had time to sit down
to really I don't feel like that's game
of the year material run around has been
some things going now you know cuz I
wanted to try the money and you know I
knew there's gonna be conversation the
game of the year don't care what oh boy
I've been playing a smash though man
crack man I can't add a baby what can I
say
a little too boy fighting game for
whatever reason for now for now right so
what do you call me Lord sleep when I
was here before you King David so I'm
like you know what I'm going to mix the
watch because this that chrome and gold
don't look like you got
that's about it really
everybody I saw like I said you just
went back to smash she said right so the
only thing I'm able to play on the go so
yes mash and that's it like I play a
little bit ashen and a little bit of
below yesterday maybe like you like I
like below man like I did you know the
tiny little character thing is kind of
annoying but beyond that like I like
Tommy you know the setting and the
ambience seems cool
I don't haven't seen much of the actual
gameplay so I don't know what it's for
the gameplay okay and of course you know
we got the Incredible Hulk Ernest aka
the XS game the lord of combat sports
who's a man of his convictions demands
nothing less than that premium
experience and is the leader of the
fraud alert movement beloved Lord King
how you doing sir I'm called a florida
or sovereign my gang but the played in
the dlc this week so mugging yes
laughing
shoutout to the fraud of snake oil
salesman it hurts for an honored crap
Hido last names of the hot mess garbage
like something that you don't put your
eyes upon and I don't recommend anybody
watch that that shouldn't even count on
somebody's record
no Hans Nell agree which we said crap
right crab spice under cards were much
better the undercard was fighting for a
check I was playing this week I
definitely played that below I want to
give a shout-out to some of my my
youtubers that I am really digging their
content right now let's go review
million was oh my gosh like a rim really
picking his stuff right now cold
what is so underrated he gave a tutorial
breakdown mmm next Xbox and the next
Playstation stuff coming for dummies
like if you are dummy you don't
understand what stuff you know what
anything means he breaks it down in a
way that you can understand you can
follow a normal round of force
narratives and that man Johnny on the
scene dealer has a way of Northmen pops
up you were hit on it he on it ready
and giving you information straight from
awesome up boom he opens credits the
people that he get it to sources that he
give you without giving you a fact
behind it
zeyneb dudes and I do with that too I'm
looking at they dominated my YouTube
viewing like I want to shout out on Lady
Erica from other press star she's got
one up right now on below - it is really
good - so yeah a salute to her as well
depressed our crew Kofi and a crew
he's on touch a touch double oh okay
okay
touch the ashes shout out the hip-hop
gamer for sending me Soul Calibur oh
yeah shout hip hop yeah yeah I got that
twice he see some either did Lux joy and
I don't know how stop playing fighting
games because that game is utterly
amazing made me go back and play my
Tekken I'm gonna know who you're
checking this week um
touch my ashen and of course destiny is
on another level right now yeah I'm just
waiting for spider-man DLC this week of
course we every gaming man himself the
shinobi Laura kognito spreading
everyoneís in the realm with the ILP not
tell me what you want to hear but what
you need to hear so before I get into
what I was playing huge iron loss salute
to Lord boomstick accel last night show
or double barrel that's one of the
coolest things anyone has ever done for
the Lord there's a spotlight proud to
call you a true friend to the realm
brother classic gaming stories the
fields were legendary
please Lords if you are not already
subscribed to this guy please subscribe
to double-barrel gaming truly one of the
good guys in our gaming community as far
as on games myself arm Smash Bros
definitely got it rocking with that oh
shut up
- chief Tommy the chief table yet Yoshi
fish he showed me the hustle right now
baby I would like your characters you're
good looking out you tell because I
didn't want to do that grind and he got
me a locking character sir you want that
hustle please Paulette she can unlock
your characters left or right so I'll be
doing that you know saying I did I
didn't get a chance to play the Soul
Calibur yet downloaded that still doing
my arm destiny - black army PC shot -
all bar and the crew I'm almost ready
I'm almost ready I'm getting me they
trying to get me but I'm like not ready
yet I'm not gonna be helping nobody my
low light trouble getting that but um
yeah man I spent less pretty much it for
me so I'm Oh real quick song did you all
catch that Oh UFC last night oh the only
thing I caught was the main event which
is Kevin Lee vs. I came to - mom I can
take it - keV
yeah you know my guys it was a good
fight but I tell you this like you know
how I feel about dudes coming down to
the ring a little too full of themselves
yeah Kevin Lee and [ __ ] and driving
he got in there and Ally keeps a head
and foot man I have to give to a lot
Quinta he's constantly improving his
crap that this is a guy that people tend
to be say he's a good fighter but he's
gonna stand in front of you throw
punches mm-hmm last night there was more
technique he was his sidekick the the
timing on his punches like he has
improved considerably he took it to
Kevin Lee and you need to see the
replays of Kevin Lee's face when he
loses the disease its class it is meme
worthy but pretty much all I saw but
that was very fight yeah Michelle Tyler
came here because at the end of the day
you know he do have his number he was
talking some real talk at the end in a
fight you can catch that like it was
awesome I already knew he was gonna
break like he's not built for the deep
water like he was he was really talking
at talk on Kevin Lee so the thing with
cabbages so much to talented I don't
know if he's gonna have to move up he's
always gassed and always looking always
had issues with making weight it's fight
like he's gonna have to figure out what
his comfort zone is and you know if
that's closer to his walking around
weight then so be it but you have to be
able to last a fight so facts yeah so
suit again well you know what always
showed me saw is how tough could be be
like we've just read do i iook into like
you know yeah and it's just like and I
know Kevin was talking that talk took a
beat but it's like you're not on that
level so that's just what it is no one
in the crowd yeah yeah yeah big kid I
got a shirt with him with the two feet
as a child you wrestle bears yes thank
God you don't mess with dad we got into
what the Lord's have been playing you
know and all that good stuff I want to
start off with Lord Brown
his videogame system history his
affection for the PlayStation brand and
his journey as a content creator that
would lead him to the entire PlayStation
bra movement so Lord Brown let's start
from the beginning what was some of the
first video game systems you had and
what got you into gaming hey dude
the very first system I ever owned was a
Nintendo NES man my brother had no Mario
mmm I guess we got it we got it for
Christmas or something by member Mayan
and I'm like oh my god this little
jumping on these turtles is so addicting
it just heard from there man you know it
no Super Nintendo mm and then I kind of
got bored with the end walked into one
day okay so give me give me some autumn
games but that little sad okay I had
Wild Arms 3 I mean I'm sorry Wild Arms
Wow though Final Fantasy 7 whoo and I'm
like I'm gonna put this Wild Arms game
looks pretty cool you know it's a
Western RPG so I let my friend borrow
7mn you can play that tell me if it's
good or not I got I got kind of stuck in
blonde arms grinding too much Oh Mike
mans is getting aggravating my friend
got stuck in 7 he gave it back and I
started playing 7 I'm like oh my god
what was I thinking that changed it man
promised 7 changed everything for me
that I've never played RPGs that much
I'm Super Nintendo
Real Talk I mean there's Chrono Trigger
Final Fantasy no 3 4 5 and I don't
believe I skipped I don't think there'll
be another game quite like 7 late yeah I
think I can captivate you in the way
that me
way dude I think what it was bro you're
completely right because as I had the
SNES and I mean okay no I was frauding
on the RPGs for the would have realized
well you're on to something because it's
something about Final Fantasy 7 not only
graphically for its time it was
outstanding but it casualized rpgs for
the mainstream to make it acceptable I
think with that one wasn't because of
the CD space they really wanted to
actually show what the PlayStation can
do yeah when you first summon oh yeah oh
my god our cinemas over and over laughs
I mean I necessarily think it was you
know maybe at that time but even to this
day that games beloved it is to me it
isn't the best Final Fantasy I think
it's it's the most important one for a
lot of reasons what you guys said like
if you guys remember the marketing push
for that game in those commercials all
the cutscenes I was like it was all
cutscenes and people want to have played
play you know probably more Final
Fantasy anyone in this panel why you
know I personally like nine more but I
do think the best one is seven yeah the
importance of seventeen hordes of seven
I give away five even that I I think it
has the better story by far I like the
three better
I like brains all of them because of the
job system when they introduced a job
system to Final Fantasy Tactics made me
love RPGs and half my ps1 collection
in RPGs just because of seven I mean and
totally change me as a gamer we came no
Melkor solid I realized that gaming was
about to come a cinematic experience
whoa
full voice acting the cutscenes crazy
convoluted story line the convoluted the
lolly lolly yeah longer solid worn all
the gameplay tricks you know Paul you
controlling the port to your defeat
oh yeah I don't if we want a little mind
and then you know you're coding hell
yeah this is a Java Bali sister Cody
that was but I love characters yeah
crazy I got them all Final Fantasy seven
with the material continued browser the
the ps1 has changed my my love for
gaming it took it like I said it had the
Super Nintendo I had like 40 games form
as Ward with it mmm man needs something
more from we keep gaming and that's what
the PS board did it for you grabbed me
was like come to me myself little
magnets like that
then going with the CD base in attend
over fusing imagine if Nintendo would
have went with CD bays and square we
never would have went to Sony thing
changes but see this is what I'm telling
you you have seized the opportunity and
every turn and Sony seize the
opportunity that game was monumental and
pushing them into the hearts and minds a
Japanese game you you know what though
King I think that that proves one thing
hmm that Nintendo's been messing up
pretty hardcore for 15 what champions
they were they don't want to be thrown
Sega right oh you said these guys
actually is rock you know I obviously
think we should think Sega dethroned
second in a way
silence because this company has been
screwing up for like like a long time
it's somehow they still rose I'm sorry
that this might be a little did you guys
hear it like I don't know if anyone
hears really played smash online have
you I meant like the actual system smash
like the online system yo tell me how
they go make a online search engine for
what you want and they say I want to
play 1v1 I want to please you know 2v2
3v3
you know you give the criterias that you
want to play but how tell me how its
connection base so regardless what you
put and you'll get connected with
someone that has about the same
connection is you so it doesn't matter
what you want to play you got matched up
to pity over your connection I hate but
in a way that's kind of good
I just wanna 1v1 none of the extra [ __ ]
and then you get Maggie into something
that has nothing you're right you a if
it's not completely criteria you want
yeah I see you see I was just looking at
it from a connection stable but but
you're right if that's not the mode you
want or whatever I hear what you say but
back back to Brooke I want to ask him
one question about the Sony ps1 era that
I don't think we touched on for me that
what grabbed it was how arcade perfect
their ports were like I remember going
to the arcade and seeing Tekken 1 and
that was the same thing in my home and
oh my god it's ticking yeah like I
remember seeing Ridge Racer in house and
back yeah it will more features right
and Ridge Racer in okay it's the same
thing take a three oh my god listen for
Tekken 3 we all of us I think it was
seven of us we hopped on a train like at
7 o'clock in the morning we got
word at one of our spots in Brooklyn had
it like deep at the ass-end of Brooklyn
we were on the train at 7 o'clock in the
morning to get bit again the final like
seven or eight import copies they had we
were back home by 9 o'clock clean second
three without modded place the spring
thaw with the eraser
come on give me some more time titles in
it what else are ladies present evil -
okay ooh I bombed that game it I think I
was what 13 my pre-order that game paid
my own money
mm-hmm I'm mature tide although like
here you go sir Mike hell yeah I'm out
of that store man whoo regular to get to
40 minutes while the remake buddy d3 my
heart was just a sea of love nostalgia
we couldn't keep you out of that section
at e3 we was there I love stuff like
that though ma'am how they went all
extravagant had the police station in
the cop car zombies it was so good to
debut of the Nemesis aka dawn we used to
call them affectionately and don't I'd
never forget that when I did clearance
quests on the second playthrough man I
didn't expect because the game yeah but
I've never been so more scared in my
life with that like that was insane
rod Cochran sedan from PS 1 you just
went straight into oh yes - look dude
that was the first console I bought my
own money
mmm I had that Folgers coffee can full
of change whoa oh I cashed him had 250
bucks I had some money left over from
working that summer and I walked into
Walmart look I need that PS to give us
memorable console I had was the n64
because I remember waking up it was
Christmas my dad got me okay now explain
to me how I get up and then like it's
already open he's like look man I
like you're gonna have to deal with the
being open I wanted to play stuff and
you it wasn't Christmas so you
I didn't CC for showers empire that was
a great game that's good
what twenties I got on Glover and Rogue
Squadron unlike the two games I got with
it in like thinking about it now it's
like why didn't he even open it those
games weren't exactly the greatest ages
to hike man he was due definitely too
high they they are making a glove or two
for the switch like oh I know I did I'm
gonna get that time safe
so ps2 bag you see shadows bro what you
had a shout the Colossus ff10 voice
acting man oh my gosh they finally had
voice acting you had that annoying as I
like that they mad remembered a debut
man King literally stood on line for it
was a guy that was there a week ahead of
when we saw Madden and shiny heads but
he eyes was within the googly eyed man
dude remember all that sweetness took
for me when I first saw it because I got
so sick of tired of playing game date
nano how it looked on the PlayStation 1
and you know games and stuff when I saw
that Madden and I stole the shoulder
pads around whoa the helmet was around
and he's got as was cool you know legs
like I mean it was like the bigs right
for real that was one of mine and I
finessed news that day that day I I sold
remember I sold it a piece of paper for
five hundred dollars yes
mm-hmm right - yes I take it you didn't
get a Playstation so when we went in
then didn't take my so when I got
outside I said yo who wants to go get a
Playstation because it was turning
people away if you don't have a ticket
you wasn't getting one so your boss said
you did the original soldier boy is
telling people when they purchase
imagery and having Nintendo games and
they already they already coming for the
site watch your video rather do 20 right
now I love Richard affectionally I'm
gonna tell it he's completely wrong the
reason why there's a buffer in between
is because it's not him selling them per
se he's like go through me through
PayPal you given him an extra $90 to
actually purchase from another site if
you go to the actual site you can get it
for 319 but they still crappy system
sorry
so anyway like we've seen so that way
yeah those plea has two titles so strong
give me give you a couple more then we
move into that place the Gran Turismo 3
that's my favorite the series still even
to this day okay I played it non-stop
mm-hmm that's love the game jak and
daxter Ratchet and Clank
- great game man and that DVD player go
to DVD god no God well of course you
don't say so tell me about the
PlayStation 3 area I'm very curious
about that because obviously as Xbox
guys here reference like how would you
how did you take the launch of that
system and first of all the system was a
sexy system right yeah like yeah 600
bucks and I did not have 600 bucks
so he wasn't how maintenance girlfriends
don't allow for sister at all or ps3 but
they said you should get a second job
ever would how it is only for the simple
fact that I friendly the console looks
sexy you had the back compact the
original one had the backer it solve
didn't have Linux as OS or certainly got
my bread from that to that and it was
option oh you got it you wonder so many
losses yes right I wanted but over here
now you know what baby bad bro we gotta
talk about it this is about to go I was
so in or pierced and I'll never forget
that III and at the time you know 360s
poppy and they got Halo whatever it ps3
comes out and they show that kills
amazing yet there was like real-time
footage
I said if videogame I'll stick to this
day video games a bait-and-switch back
in PlayStation 2 with the Final Fantasy
remember with all the other and there's
a yo way to do with a real time now it
was so much it took so much anger away
from Microsoft at that time cuz
everybody was all the fanboys picked a
side they was like yo that's real
everybody was like gasps no as in -
that's the cell that's with the Sun I
mean Killzone 2 did look good look like
to this day Killzone Shadowfall game
even though I said on Twitter about the
dude I don't know we have a chat right
now I want everybody to know like we're
not phonies we're not fakes we're not
fraud alright so we actually a 90% of
the people that's on this podcast and
it's gas and stuff like that we actually
know all right and we actually hang out
with now we set up the castle in Cali
when we were going to III and you know
we have the bed listings and stuff like
that shout out to Jay Doug you're
supposed to be there unfortunate things
happen and he wasn't able to make it but
we were going to do like uh yeah exactly
like PlayStation projet dubs can you
know talking about we had a whole thing
set up button so we're flying in I am
everybody's trying to link up with
people I've never met PlayStation bro in
the flesh right so um we link and he's
landing when I'm landing right so he
lands and we're texting back and forth
he's like will you have a thumb up on
the third floor I'm waiting for the uber
to come so my hope is coming he shows up
and we're going to go pick up the car so
as we're going to go pick up a car plank
position brother - know what I rented
right when when they bring down the car
they bring down the red cherry crazy bro
just one point we stopped in someone in
their SUV goes I'll race you for pink
slip or something like that Dave goes
huh huh takes off my stomach full of
game laughs but we had such a great time
axé me let me tell you I love how scary
it was amazing management everybody was
doing at whiskey we had little King in
me our County crew at the rule everybody
was there better live and so so just
meeting him for the first time and and
bonding with him
we actually have a connection and
sharing that with him why he could tell
you stories I want to tell you but we
had such a great time Oh shopping man
III 2018 was off the hook it was it was
so much fun so much fun but shot the
punch of the chat yes salute the work I
did agree I don't meet many minutes shy
salute to you brother so yeah back to
the brother so yeah so that you can say
yeah I did three and like I said and I
at that time will you even sway by 360
at any any point or you still can't have
one eventually Mass Effect dude
I love sapphires mmm that's what's up I
mean I mean I am I am a PlayStation
enthusiast what everyone call me let me
out game on all the consul's I got a
switch I've had now I'm sort of the
gamer my love PlayStation but I can't
won anything dude if a game looks cool
to me I'm on it I'd have Xbox one yet so
I bought the Windows 10 version of
cuphead just for the play anywhere you
know no I have not done I'm so close I
played for like two hours at a time just
non-stop it's repeating what I can and
then just get aggravated and stop for a
month or two yeah me too I wait for that
back over there's a boss one company
that's a robot Leia I lost like some of
my sanity would that dude watch the
livestream I stopped playing the game I
watched your livestream assist me namaka
bottom class
I can't I was so excited when I meeting
that robot dude I bought him for like
two like two days of like five our
streams yo shout out that undid I was
I'm in the same type of time he's like I
broke two controllers on carpet
I was so excited I had it like remind
myself to breathe yeah pass out weapon
dude though so real quick before we get
into what you transition to now just
about the PlayStation 4
obviously this is one of Sony's rest
areas so like how do you re ps3 how do
how do you feel like with the ps4
generation and how great so he's doing
like like is this the greatest Sony
system to you in awe of all time damn
that's a big question I had to ask you
bro
you know I'm always partial to ps1 and
ps2 because MN really got me too but you
know if someone just jumped into the ps4
ecosystem with the ps4 mm-hmm
then they they probably like damn this
is good [ __ ] yeah this is when the ps3
was it took a couple years it wouldn't
go out to 2010 in my opinion it really
started kicking thanks thanks 2009 kind
of that Eric no milk or salt for came
along mm-hmm and it was 24 hours of
cutscenes and we walk to the next you
know it took some time for the ps3 to
pick up steam question so let's get into
your journey on YouTube obviously and
the creation of the PlayStation brahs
calm website and then obviously will let
you to form the broadcast and shout to
your team cuz it was a craving art well
so annisquam
jade of course it's kind of like a
rotating crew people who Misha psvr from
the side he's on there sometimes the
indie legends Alden Alden bear from
arcade that's uh former digital hoarders
you know it's yes we all kind of just
give and take it's kind of been a little
desolate at the moment but just had a
baby you know the Lord right now little
Brock
works me kicking my butt unfortunately
it's for you brother tell me how you got
into to YouTube like what what made you
push to get into the game we've always
done videos in the past like stupid you
know college humor crap
a little superhero it's a lot - that's
totally from tub subject was on Twitter
one day oh my man gaming so good right
now
mm-hmm I just feel like it's a good time
to get back into it I think I have an
opinion that people might care to hear I
jumped on Twitter but I'm fortunate when
I first jumped on there it was like
toxic Pony stuff yeah what did I call it
no what what quantum break right mm-hmm
I call it quantum broke thing man that's
you know I was a little toxic and I mean
oh I was like Xbox sucks
oh you was the first three months in
2016 yeah it was bad man oh yeah we got
it's gonna be one of the things but you
have a scandal we gotta open several
different shows of yeah and that when I
first started the bride was bad it was
really castle war was real I'm like
what's going on man this is stupid I
could do so much more with what I had
this audience mm-hmm I got to be
positive about this
it's about gaming it's about having fun
with games know getting to know other
people I could do something with this
and I want to do something with it and
interact with more people will know
interact with developers okay things are
changing or the website I try to be you
know it's positive PlayStation news I
mean I will be real yeah absolutely
I'm not like you know PlayStation is the
best Xbox can suck you know Xbox dude I
tell my riders never be like that man
that's just no we're bringing them real
news that's a sign we're not gonna no
sure code it'll be like what I mean even
some articles sometimes I'm like oh the
PSN name I change when that finally came
around
yeah I warn people and said you might
not want to do this mm-hmm oh yeah
that's gonna help me some squirrel in
the window
I told people say hey be careful Sony I
don't know if someone else what they're
doing yet you shut the alcohol as he
said peers bro is the first guy to call
it the exit oh I'm glad you made that
choice I try to keep it real on my side
it's always cuz Sony's not perfect they
are far from perfect
mm-hmm yeah one thing I gotta give you
credit is that like I feel like all your
videos are really like light-hearted but
they're really funny you know saying
you're not afraid to poke fun of
yourself man you are hilarious on camera
you're a natural camera whatever thank
you any of your little shorts kids I'm
you have a natural talent for that so
that's why I'm sending you pick videos
about construction vehicles yes I say yo
he gets me I like this kid right no
quote unquote keep it real but that's
definitely it's that's what it is so
there how did you form the team then
like how did you get what you shut down
a craving guard j-dub like how did you
form the broadcast this hey Matt I
decided hey everyone else has a show
what can I have a show blue that like
Evan me and Jada talked all the time and
mean craven craven was the first one the
first host I ever had oh wow that's what
sucks
Brock has alpha test and mmm my host and
like we had me able to get on lately
they said it's been guys with the
website I'm doing like we interviewed a
dub developer with servos the VR
developer oh wow that's what's up Geno
they made Creed Rises glory in eight
months
yeah they had learned so much with their
other games they've made and beaten the
world of VR yeah that they just they got
they had the idea they'd be knocked down
eight months - I was amazed by if y'all
played it in y'all pointed nicely now
ths playing jumping in you told me I
think I was with you
we won't pass it but yeah I played that
on the Cree game is fantastic yeah took
only eight months to make that same is
one of the best games yeah a shout-out
to you didn't she was able to secure at
least get the one of my favorite games
from Detroit the the god I played the
Android what's his name
oh that was a Brandon Brandon almost
okay I had talked to Brian Deckard about
coming on the broadcast
yeah but impotent and it was when the
time that I talked to him and we were
supposed to do it he became like super
famous ah yeah Hollywood on the bra no
no man I wasn't gonna bother him come on
it's not he's a little dog like me no
he's over here with like jacksepticeye
Troy Baker he don't have time for me I'm
not gonna bother the guys let me give
you real quick what's the bucket list
what's the was easy like Laden is it you
see what's the like the garland I'm
Midlands okay Laden I met you mmm-hmm
it's Kojima man I've been close ok 2010
I worked for PlayStation lifestyle right
okay we go to e3 in California mm-hm
we go to a Starbucks that that we got we
go to get our badges we go to a
Starbucks on the way back cuz we're
almost no jet lag your little tired
oh I'm sitting in Starbucks and get my
coffee I turn around there's a little
asian man sitting outside the window oh
it is her day Okajima and we've ah
paused and he instantly no yes okay you
know my jaw drops I'm like guys it's
kijima I mean I've never been so nervous
in my life so I go outside and there's
these two other people like standing
about five feet from him I said excuse
me I know at that time I had a little
digital camera no little camera that
lost in the show but uh I'm like hey I'm
sorry to bother you but could I please
get a picture with Kojima II know he's
yeah they were developer created like no
no he's tired he needs trying to relax
I'm like please please like no no no
sorry I've been through that bro hey let
me tell you I was crushed man I was
broke I had the same exact experience my
first III ever III 2015 and the way you
felt before
that's how I felt for you Suzuki but
it's a so I'm going
Genma baby and he's in the Sony section
I'm going crazy and he's got the whole
you know he's got like the unit like a
uh uh uh you'll see like a secret
service unit around wheels it so I'm
trying to like you know and I got the
cam nay like knifing okay so I had to
try to sneak a big [ __ ] or to pass
through your ass it was my older we
would understand these guys they get
inundated with a ton of requests PSX
2017 he was walking past us and so
people got to him before we did and then
he ran on my break we gotta get to you
before you man boys days I'm gonna meet
him and thank you let me tell you all
you guys get next to Geoff Keighley
yeah that's right if Kanye can do it
dammit hey LeBron can do it though they
the last question I got for you bro of
course the greatest name PlayStation
ISTE how did the broad name started that
good I love that day I think it's the
greatest name how did you get that bad
look just meet Thomas Williams okay this
is some plane we know American name it
boring I got a friend he's metal um to
death he's kind of meathead and he
always uses bra it's always my bra
I'm going to gym today Brogdon go along
love betrayed for listening man I love
you to death man always show the tray
you me spider-man
okay I was just kind of like you know
the PlayStation guy I'm I don't work I'm
like wait wait wait bra it just come
cells good and it could be this
character uh I mean it's you know it is
me but when I first kind of started
doing is more of a character yeah yeah
and then it's slow like wait that is me
what am I saying
I took pictures of the hackers I thought
it was so cool the glasses
stay that way that's what he went took
off him that's what you wave I've always
loved aviators wanna I don't know why
these look so cool to me they kind of
fit my face good so
it's just become like this no persona
and it's just me man I'm just a
fun-loving guy that loves a game and
talked to game hang up my friends and
know my family and thank you for having
me on man I'm really honoured yet we
find things out and one thing people got
to know about the brothers like
everything that you see on a video or
when he's on a car that's who you yeah
in real like if this man was teasing me
joke and he was doing the same tags that
he would normally - question for you
called oh here we go hick of the cab Joe
caftan son he's killing me because he's
like your car cog we skipping leg day I
see the jokes we had at County was
classic Luke to the brother have you and
I gotta ask you a question I ask all the
guests Oh top five games or franchises
of all time for Lord Brown whatever your
this is your personal father gave the
five games that either impacted you in
your mind with your five greatest games
it's a lot of older games that's the
problem Super Mario Brothers because it
got me in gaming no doubt there we go
I mean okay I mean I can't forget no
jumping through the ceiling and run into
those secret rooms Wow can skip have to
get ff7 dude I mean it changed gaming
for me change the game change the game
facts Noel what else what else we got
Final Fantasy 7 you guys know what else
we got we got three more cobble rez evil
- oh just the memories for it man I'll
never forget that game the damn
alligator trying to eat me oh my god
here's another one okay Mortal Kombat
Oh first one I've
going to arcade and walking for his
mortal combat then that's also undo the
scorpions finisher oh my oh my god what
is this game big fellow
tell okay sorry
it was real it was on a body experience
like doing it like they're actually
killing three fighter to know you winner
it's to had like he had a piece of paper
oh I was like how are they doing this
how do you get no play with this
language was heads off they had these
have substance or held the spine on my
ear oh this game is crazy
yeah what a car that change the gate
that's a good yeah I think you're the
first yes sir
safe I know what to say more definitely
say Mortal Kombat that yeah that's
what's up so we got motorcar you say
Street Fighter was what LSO no no it's
close though it's cool so we got one big
Wall Street buyer to cuz I mean it did
change fighting games forever but more
will come it just made this impression
on me it just okay this game is a poor
get away with it so we are Resident Evil
2
we got Super Mario as the first one we
got Mortal Kombat so you got two more do
I know this won't sound crazy but mmm
ready well for was also on that list all
addict love you beat that game like five
times now as a franchise yeah you you
could take okay maybe five and six were
I beat him don't get me wrong the racism
was too much
[Laughter]
Evan came back seven was strong y'all
played seven yeah seven are so strong
that's what says you don't resonate
venir all right what you got two more
come on I wouldn't say my will my
favorite game but one my games I'll
never forget like on PlayStation is
parappa the original parappa door and
still singing those songs to the day
please brother tell me that that did
that inspired on PlayStation bro raps
did you be doing oh no my dad always he
always sings songs and I got that from
him and then I start making my own songs
up and whatnot and so you're dizzy lover
you did chat forever a part of me wishes
I could write music he said you could be
friends with him now parappa the rapper
yes he's all smoke was he not watching
the beginning the show I had the beanie
on
yeah you had to be in everything
literally at the very beginning show do
it is a true that's what's up man so
finish it off one last one cause we gave
Resident Evil as a two-piece
well last one out here yet I've always
been charted I'm all about those games
I'm surprised you two have less of us in
it though just go put it in it I think
it is a great game a fantastic game but
I'm not like some kind of gaming
that's what say yo I do love Mega Man 2
Mega Man series classic first 7 you know
mmm listen bros a classic man you got
strong strong less man slow to the bra
games answer no questions man we go get
it to the topics man last week's poll
results are in and the people have
spoken to the question in regards to
Phil Spencer's latest comments from
regarding Xbox game pass
eventually coming to every device do you
interpret this as game pass definitely
coming to PlayStation Nintendo
which in the near future the winner as
61% was the no complete overreaction
Xbox game pass is strictly for project
as cloud TVs phones and tablets group
coming in at second place at 23% was the
yes Phil is literally spelling it out
for you open your eyes accommodated a
fairly last place at a 60 percent was
that I don't care unless I could run
game pass on my toaster group thanks to
all the Lord's if last week's poll the
poll was lit over like 500 participants
to shout out to that you know why well
glue tell you what I think about times
man paid up took it to the necklace
shout out to cradles he took it to the
next level I'm ready to play hail
infinite hydrate us when you do some
stuff like that on that they reach out
the ten dog and get a balanced you said
yes to pull common-sense prevent the
poll was pretty divisive Lord saw what
do you think about that I gotta listen
man I gave to me they listened if if
Xbox goes away the dodo for whatever
reason is fails then yes yeah I can see
them morning to be everywhere but not it
not until that happens but we did see a
kind of cryptic tweet from Lord jazz a
little bit it just seems that the walls
seem to be closing in on Steam and
they're looking for help like mr. Lee
like come out pretty at once that was
cryptic is AF okay exactly you already
know so let's get to these topics Lord
addict are you there sir yes I mean all
right Kingdom Hearts 3 convince us Oh
back I vote over for Lord Ram says when
bill says everything he means everything
shall preach the gospel
for example we go get it to the Lord
addict man Kingdom Hearts 3 what is
going on uh I was we were just gonna
talk about you know the console but last
night I didn't realize there's actually
a lot more going on with Kingdom Hearts
they know it's out there bro imagine a B
I'm trying to find your copy right now
I'm going into the deaths right now to
try to find you go somehow about 30 to
35 copies and then I think someone stole
about 4 truck oh damn yeah there are
people out there like I used to be in
like this this Facebook group earth
thing that was Kingdom Hearts I've been
in there for years and last night I I
went on it and people were trying to
spoil the game on there I left the group
and it read anything I left the group
like you know they're selling them for
like $300 on after the two so yeah
you're caught in possession of one of
these you gonna get a charge they did a
public public announcement that they're
coming they're gonna go after these
people of everything that got Wow so as
of right now the entire game like
they're spoiling the entire game they're
even spoiling their secret cutscene
that's at the end of the game I don't
know if this was good in place already
but they apparently yesterday they also
said that I may be to combat this that
there's gonna be they're adding the
epilogue with the day one patch hey I'll
break it down now peep what you're
saying that people already physically
have the finished game they're in
possession or they stole it like how how
did this go down
do you know to to my knowledge someone
it was neither done one out of two ways
because they haven't come openly out out
and said which one it is neither someone
got their hands on one of the processing
plants of them packaging it this is a
hole they were put they were loaded one
of the workers took an entire box off
one of the trucks
Wow they say salty right now that's
crazy
they got okay so now the other thing I
saw the game director he tweeted a
statement in reference to it so he it
was pretty much like um I can actually
go ahead and read to you what he said
hey let me ask you one question
yeah good bro there's already copies out
in the wild won't they release to go
ahead and release it early and the
game's already printed I mean what the
hell why wait I don't think it's printed
like that like oh is it gold
yes gold they could release a digital
because the game just went the pre-order
just went up like a couple days ago
gotcha okay they pretty much took it
from the in the processing when they
were wrapping the cases in so they took
it at the early I don't even think it's
been shipped out yet that's good yeah
here's what he said he said we're aware
that the small portion of Kingdom Hearts
3 has been circulating online before
it's official released and also aware
that somehow we are also aware how it
happened we're sorry to see this caused
concern among our fans or you know
excited for the release the whole team
has been working together since
yesterday night Japanese time to
investigate and what we can do better in
this situation but first we would like
to ask that you do not share these
videos the guy's overloading the secret
movie which are the biggest spoilers in
a game or plan to be released at a later
date
just in case they would not
shown before the release date we want
everyone to be able to equally
experience the cool game after its
release shout out the boss boos he said
shout to mr. Lee for selling Kingdom I
think I made that phone call right when
you call right you call and the dude
picks up and he's like no now we don't
have them like can I talk to mr. Lee
please you know tell them my name no no
no no no I did you know you need to
speak directly to what's going on is let
me give you like a brief like we like
anyone that's playing keno Mart's we
don't really know where this game's
gonna start mmm it could start multiple
different places but you know there's
not really you know how most games you
know over the sequel's gonna start you
know it got a war you kind of knew where
it was got like no one knows where this
game strollin good and no one knows
where it's ending and that is what
they're spoiling is their sport you got
kids you got to think about like people
were waiting for this game for six to
seven years it's nice it's nice no you
know why the power of the you can click
on that link if you want addict chose
not to click on that link mmm now if you
want to put bloody your own snow that's
your own business you know for the
company that you come out and say yo
don't share this no oh you know what it
is that better security don't
because some of these people are making
it like a choice why they're just
posting it and sometimes when you're
scrolling through Twitter or something
yeah it's too late you've already CD I
was going through game facts just to see
like the tea you know they get the bread
crumbs and game facts and you see where
were you know who has it and where they
got it from whatever
so there are dip that they're like posts
in game tracks saying please put
spoilers here boilers in this chat like
we want to know this stuff I don't know
why you will be spoiled on this go to
camera they know who got it they said we
are on this dude we found out where he's
at
we're trying to track him down and get
we understand that part right there and
what's funny is the dudes not even a
gamer you just worked at the processing
plant bad for man cuz it's like damn you
know especially it's so high and highly
anticipated don't click it yeah you know
last thing I want to ask brothers
question because I was very confused
with this game like is this game doesn't
Microsoft who has the marketing rights
because I had no clue it is distracting
every PlayStation 2 console is a common
told that Microsoft has the marketing
rights like but then like you see
something like that but then you see
them have a bundle like yeah every time
this game has shown up at a conference
has been Microsoft's right last year it
was everywhere it was on all the stages
do so like son was everywhere ya know
get bro
I still can't believe they didn't
release the first few games nice box
yeah that's what I was gonna do I think
it might be PlayStation as the
PlayStation has to have the marketing
rights well they have exclusive content
right because if you revisit that
statement that they just release you
know they got the Kingdom
style pro version one terabyte DualShock
force us to look pretty cool he's got a
turn coming oh and you get the physical
copy of Kingdom Hearts now what they're
saying is exclusive content or keys yeah
so out that would lead me to believe
that yes they do have okay a ps4
exclusive digital content and although
it isn't clearly the physical this game
was debuted on all three stages I've
never seen this I was just very curious
my dad brought finish off someone said
back in the day when Square Enix almost
when they made the Final Fantasy movie
net bomb Spirits Within and Sony bailed
him out and so he came in and bought
some of their shares whatever reason
they they a lot of stuff is only on
PlayStation that like 10 years like they
had pretty much they own screen almost
went under Square Enix bought them back
from them bought them back that's when
you saw Final Fantasy 13 come on Xbox
mmm got you so add a guy just in general
like I know this is a big big title for
even waiting for this for a long time
like where's your head at now with spoil
anything and then what about I wanted to
ask you this like what about for a
person like me who's the noob who don't
know nothing about the game you know I'm
saying like why is just one put it off
is not the one for you like this people
I know that that played them all
multiple times and stuff no clue what
this games about like again I'm just
gonna jump in I'm gonna get you a song
but like but think about it is is like I
wanna like it look cool it got to got to
junior PG vibe that our style alike but
then when I see Goofy and Donald Duck
something like if you can't get over
that then you can't play it can I get
the version where they kill them off in
the game like what party is like a charm
if people like oh I can't you know
Mickey in the game I'm like Mickey the
most badass character Keyblade doing
backflips off buildings and stuff the
story like why are they there what like
is this just on xbox yeah I think
IGN has a couple of videos I'm not going
back to bleeding hearts wanted they're
really outdated one I'd be ok because
the story so calm no you wouldn't
even remotely comment on the third ones
you gotta watch that keep don't be late
again go put into work and get but see
you can't get past Mickey if you can't
there's just stay away from it if you
plug one into and dream Drop Distance I
think you'll be pretty good don't you
agree you gotta play berth pontoon or
you're confused that's true yeah it's a
prequel the whole series if you don't
play back home to dream Drop Distance so
you get the
lord Corneil about 15 years after the
first one came out the or like the
prequel comes out this before that's
what's confusing no one knows what order
to play these games in weight of the
treehouse comic star was like the fifth
game it's technically the last game
choppy Johanna he said and that's not
counting the BS games that have lots of
info this is in the bushes this isn't
this is too much this is too much forget
it I'll just have to live vicariously
through you saw what do you think about
all this like Kingdom awesome medicine
like I understand people's love for the
series I really really do a penis Disney
is there is no hating I'm just not gonna
play it like I can't no I mean it comes
out the same days res evil so that says
oh it's definitely in the bush always
never like I'm bad for destiny destiny
three in Kingdom Hearts 3 came out the
same day there might be seven remakes
the only thing I play over when he was
dying for that only talked about you he
didn't kiss no the games talked about it
was just that one game we sat in the
room and everybody was doing a show like
go the next time you have a little bit
of time go look up Kingdom Hearts 3
announcement reactions listen because it
was about 10 to 15 years what was 15
about about 7 years in every year at e3
people's like Kingdom Hearts 3 and
analysis you it got to the point where
fans thought it wasn't never gonna
happen
yeah no let me tell you I was doing a
theater you know was Sony dinner and um
during their conference no I'm talking
about in 2013 but do that there's but
I'm just talking about the reaction of
when this was released and I'm seeing
chrome people crying like it was
emotional I was like
crying of the game was coming out here
don't do this a game that's coming you
did not make it you did not you just
play in the game
now you can cry but it's coming out
[Music]
right now he said and he noticed five
Makena bus three holy goes
people emotional facial expressions in
the bushes so we get into it man so that
we got um Ark released on the switch and
I'll let attic handle that part but I
want to forget about this this is a
google topic would be attic so you know
before you today forget about the Xbox
two with a Playstation ah let's get it
to the real powerhouse in these console
wars got their new switch Pro rumors out
here baby let's go so first off we all
know from the beginning that uh The Wall
Street Journal had first announced that
they wouldn't the first to kind of bring
it to attention and thing we're coming
out Nintendo plans a new switch version
next year so we kind of zoom you know a
revision is coming to some form then
obviously Reggie comes out recently in a
forbes interview and he kind of makes a
statement Akana shut that down he's like
right now we're in our second holiday
focus is making the current grantee on
switch continue to have money consumed
he said you know I was new systems and
basically says that on the current
execution of Nintendo switch right now
is a joint con in all its capabilities
and that's their focus right now so once
we got that information it was kind of
like a damper that yo it's not there's
not gonna be any pro or any type of
revision and then SNK jumps into the
scene so pretty much SNK they announced
that new a new samurai shodown game
making use of I think Unreal Engine 4
and that's suppose it's gonna be samurai
spirits and supposed to rival on the
PlayStation 4 so that was the initial
announcement and now they had a recent
SNK conference in South Korea now
they're showing like a slide and it's
showing samurai spirits for multiple
consoles right and then even a
presentation that shows a Nintendo's
logo with samurai spirits so this is
when the rumor gets little deeper now so
I wanna shout out loss spawn media and
review tech cuz they were kind of refers
to kind of really bust the story now now
there's a quote-unquote insider and
apparently he has some connections with
SNK and what's going on and he says
pretty much in a reddit post he says
switch and ps4 for now and regards to
the samurai spirits game he said no
talks on PC yet it will most likely come
out on the piece
Elena just like King of Fighters 14 but
he said believe it or not the switch is
gonna get two versions of samurai
spirits the first one is for the
original switch and the second one it's
for the new switch Pro which is going to
be quote stronger and better so I gotta
bring this back to the lords that we
hear about again this switch pro room of
resurfaces once again what do we think
about this so let's start with the bra
first so I think I already know what
king and addicts going but let's start
over what do you think about rumors of a
switch from should I be surprised I mean
is it is the pro gonna let me play arc
at 720p so do you think um first of all
brought do you think it's a go I got you
got you see dangler visual habit now
here's the next question do you think it
will be a revision or an upgrade like a
true upgrade which is kind of what this
insider guys of Lumina kind of looting -
so it's a beefier has anybody said he's
kind of loading till I didn't hear about
this man I don't know how I missed it I
mean I'm quite shocked yeah shout out to
him I want to shout out like I said
small wave media he's got a great video
up on it
shout out rich from a view tech USA he's
also on to this as well yeah one of the
- I heard the first rumors about The
Wall Street Journal
yes I remember that one like okay it's
not surprising but so somebody else is
reiterating now definitely happen so no
fans gonna be like oh I can play Animal
Crossing in 720p now or Pokemon runs
faster no doubt yes oh Lord
add it let's get you in right right
right and early what do you feel about
this and then I know how she will
transition into your market topic
annexing bushes axes continued in the
bushes
oh he's sleep on okay so he I talked
about our Lord's table
oh I really would like a switch bro
really you know what I really think the
switch was like a Testim okay I think
because they took a lost with we you and
it was trepidation probably with this
system me the look and initially when
the system was coming out people were
having reservations about it right and
then they actually got to touch the
system in their hands and it was like I
was intuitive it feels great and it took
off from there and it just like
skyrocketed and I think if they were
really sure about it they would have you
know beefed it up a little bit more of
course and the system the system would
do more than you know the 360p or
whatever the hell it does um so I think
the next system will be you know 1080p
on a resolution on the screen maybe for
the home it'll probably like 1440p a
little bit more be filled with the
polygons more output just a little bit
more because they do revisions with
these systems in line with certain games
like with the 3ds XL and it had the new
version with a faster clock on a CPU so
Nintendo has been known to tinker with
stuff I do I really think that it's
gonna happen yes but I wanted to happen
yes so they can get some more of the
third-party games the mainstream games
more on the system instead of looking
like their fury a little brother most of
the time you know cashews now let me ask
you this King like do you think like if
they go to be for your route do you
think there will be a situation where
eventually they segment the base where
you have because I again you're you're
more Nintendo than me you've been
through the recent years of me so like
when you ever segment the base what I
want to happen is well they messed up
with the three with the new three yes
one game that you can't play on other
you know things and they tell you that
it's like one or two games yeah okay
what what will happen is the newer games
will run at that new resolution then it
would be a scalable type of situation
because the architecture is the Nvidia
shield architecture the inside of it is
scalable right so it's basically just
like a regular laptop or a computer if
you have a higher version of the system
it will scale that way so if they have a
regular switch to run it 720 whatever it
does and it was scale that way so no
Nintendo will never leave other people
on winning goal from system to system
yeah they want you to purchase on a next
system but if it's in the same ecosystem
no they don't so what do you think about
these rumors or the latest one tied to
SNK I mean I definitely want it mom but
I am surprised because like King was
saying like the last time they tried
that they sort of segmented the base by
not you know by only this certain games
that only played with the newer hardware
um so I in that respect I know they've
learned a lesson that's not gonna happen
again
definitely but Nintendo's traditionally
not upgraded hardware in terms of power
especially the first iteration this is
the second iteration of a hardware like
usually it's something cosmetic you know
improving the screen and never
necessarily improving power wise so it's
but again they've seen they've seen Sony
do it they've seen Xbox do it um so it
makes sense for all the reasons that
King mentioned like it definitely it
makes sense that they would want to be
able to incorporate more and more of
these games and you know the new systems
are coming in which will further you
know make a disparity in power got your
shout out to the checkers they don't
fire rate it chief Tommy release
information how to trade in a switch
which Pro is going to finally be able to
handle YouTube app without heating up I
[Laughter]
heard it fro have a whopping 1/2 take of
it it won't be the switch Pro it will be
called the Nintendo XJ
man I hope is true I really do hope is
true because I would love uh definitely
a more powerful switch all right cool
you went dead when I asked you man
so what do you think about your chance I
[Music]
don't think this is good were they gonna
do do this so they can make Pokemon like
look a little bit better like I just
like unless they drop we're about to go
into the next generation unless they
drastically increase the power of the
switch I don't think it's gonna be
relevant to increase the power of the
switch mm-hmm what what is what is the
RAM on there like what's there was no
information did you live the only
information we have is entirely Nagar SN
pay insider who this up this new samurai
shodown games not only is it coming to
PlayStation 4 it's eventually coming out
to PC and he said the switch will get
two versions and the switch pro version
will be stronger and better that I don't
see that happening if if I see anything
they're going to be making a new switch
[Laughter]
all right so I'll be what about now in
reference to yet to happen you know
switch switch Pro might be able to help
out a Archon a switch I mean I've seen
that as really bad like I said they're
going happy we got to bring you to the
front of the congregation though you
love art but then we gotta talk about
that
well first of all shout out to our good
friend first of all god bless their
souls or who's the dev on this one yours
here god bless their inclusive souls
cuz shout out the Lord John Lennon man
digital found you to be out on the show
he had hilarious review of the Swiss
version and you know it got to a point
where the portable mode of the game can
go on to 216 P regularly so at the end
of the day we're all buddy listen
god bless your sofa tron I even
attempted they should have just did like
the raw pixels without any it's I just
bang Nintendo took the crown from the
regular Xbox but worship the worst
integration of any worse than the OG
xbox one fat face yeah it's pretty bad
man you know it should have went soceity
the resolution is so low is bad you know
it's bad song it's like bird go to
export the boy you know that when a
mobile version looks better than the
switch version like the mobile version
instead of trying to do the full port
you know I'm saying so it's like I don't
even get me started on the loading that
he had he did a side by side and it was
so bad that like he was able to play
superconscious whole first level on
Super Nintendo before the game with low
like it is insane but it's like again I
appreciate the effort for them trying to
fix but uh did you see this video no I
missed it man yeah when you get a shot
the lord thurlow
which girl Jolla and we gotta have him
back on the show says he had it was the
funniest and he's actually crowning in
the beginning like he's unprofessional
in shout that's my man I love that he
was unprofessional because I thought it
was funny
remember Santa Claus brought little bra
heart last year okay hey it fires it up
and there's like a 20 gigabyte install
mic oh my god Mike disco hands are
playing Thomas let's play it together we
did co-op and the game barely moved it
was just like okay I'm gonna stop so I
mean I was amazed that he went from with
the way it looked
yeah and then after the install with a
conclusion it was a completely looking
different looking game I could not
believe the difference that install made
I've never seen a game change like that
before
oh oh is he coming for us
yah mad he was willing to put on a
switch but okay with EA Activision
continually skipping he says playing max
playing that that okay actually see you
actively posting people to help you out
in it and I and I understand that you
are you that's your game but certain
things should not be in certain places
and that game should have never graced
the sweaty little palms of specialites
all over the world they should have
never witnessed that put the eyes on net
they should definitely get fully
reimbursed and get a free game of smash
cuz going on with his pain and suffering
but playing that game because nobody on
this planet should be able to go to the
bathroom do one and to come back and get
some and then sit down and then actually
be able to load in and play the game so
nobody should be able to do that as your
dad is truly unacceptable and this time
and date I'm happy that you got the X
version of your Ark be happy with that
that's the only version that you should
be playing on console oh but that little
thing that little system no but we said
but where's the fallout 76 refunds don't
King I don't have anything to say
there's no eulogy big enough for a grand
enough to make but yeah I had no
business being on there man like it's
the game at his core is it's made up of
systems that are kind of broken like
what would make you think that it runs
on like my thing is you're developing
this you see the product in front of you
how do you release that let's be real
like from a profitable devs have said
that when you release their title on the
switch it tends to sell more on the
verge so you don't think it's like a
date maybe it's just a victim of the
money grab but for me that applies to
indie games like a new indie games more
like you know art spin around like it
doesn't you know it's made a lot of
money right now sneaking ready to
surprise that a suspected child like you
you go and they gave me arc on the
switch I might have to kill someone I'm
I had to like it's the equivalent of
with superman 64 came out I think at
this point not had Superman 64
oh we got it we got a move over man
what's going on with these uh PC
storefront Triple Threat Wars what's
going so this is the topic that we've
actually had on a back burner a couple
weeks I know we had it on on deck and
then we couldn't get to it but man like
Steam is under attack really for the
first time and it's like 18 year history
a 15-year history oh it actually has
some competition coming down the
pipeline yeah first off we had word
earlier in the year that discord was
going to
who's gonna open its own storefront and
it has opened it for some people I think
it's in beta for some people and just
the the the fact that you have two
hundred million discord users that is a
de facto way that people chat on PC and
and probably the switch moving forward
yeah I already got family exactly school
um that poses a big threat to if they
can get the games on there pose a huge
threat to steam in terms of usership and
then then you have a big jumping into
the mix most recently saying that
they're opening their storefront and
then just like this chord as well
they're taking it to steam in terms of
that what they're charging developers to
be able to publish on their platform no
steam has generally followed the the of
the mantra that they take 30 percent
yeah all right so it's a range of 20 to
30 percent mom of revenue from a game
that's published on the platform
depending on how much the game sells at
the game sells some insane amount of
money like ten thousand two million
dollars worth of profit or something
like that
then cut is smaller mm-hmm oh so now if
you look at this cord this cord promised
something in the range of like a 10 90
to 10 percent cut so now developers on
this court are gonna be getting ninety
percent of the revenue from that and
that's and that's actually one upping
epic when epic initially said that they
were going to it's gonna be an eighty
eight to twelve and split alright
mmm-hmm the most interesting and that
all of this is really interesting
because you know and the steams never
been under attack like this right right
but I got a I got a shifted direct to
epic because I think everything epic is
doing is based off the strength of one
thing fortnight right fortnight is the
impetus for them to believe that they
can take on juggernut the Jess I doubt
the public
to that facility versus now for stealing
a versus epic with it with this cut that
they're giving developers right they're
also gonna be letting developer self
publish so the cut might even be bigger
then the recent news that they're giving
away the tech that allows them to do
cross play across backs everybody yeah
you go here you go guys yeah huge like
playstation bro same wrote I'm gonna
tell you right now we're gonna have this
discussion in a year year and a half
what as of right now what my fortnight
is my game of the generation it has the
most profound impact on this generation
there's nothing coming close to the
impact this game is had in this
generation um and if and if really is
able to make a dent in the juggernut
that is steam and with this court by its
side cuz at this point even though
they're all competing for the same space
it feels more like they're eat
discordant are individually coming at
steam rather than at each other and it's
like they want a tax theme first and
then they attack each other once theme
is out of the way we got if we look at
the matchup right we know steam has been
the dominant de facto factor it's the
magic everybody's out here with the
chairs is table beautiful I bring down
Microsoft we're gonna buy this thing I
wonder what steam to get crushed in the
face
I want them saying that epic and uh and
discord is gonna punch up Steve so bad
that they soda Micah's listen yeah like
I said before Lord escorted got a tree
horn and he tweeted tweet this morning
we yeah what would you guys think if
Microsoft partnered with steam to
leverage team to move steam games
through X cloud
why would you say that I see that part
ringing right now go back to fill shirts
mm-hmm go back to fill shirts not too
long ago wasn't he didn t have on a
steam shirt not too long ago and
everybody was it was speculating a valve
shirt yeah sure but I feel right but
it's calculated his his gear is put
together right so when his gear is put
together yeah maybe that deal was talked
about it was on the table and it getting
manifested but I believe that these type
of moves I didn't see Eric doing this I
did not see this and like Salman said
the strength of that fortnight has gave
them a certain type of power like when
they told Playstation get out of lay
down and PlayStation was like not gonna
bend the knee right so in this whole
thing in the way that is structuring and
this chord has the base already got the
people is their instruction that's right
that they're ready to attack in that
form right so how can seem fight off
these two how can it really happen again
if if you say with epic service if they
do something that incorporates sport man
in a way that if you subscribe to their
service hmm that fortnight and all its
DLC is free something of that nature
whoa actually put steam under hmm here's
the thing shout the potentially
perfectly sure he said I'm telling you
right now PC gamers are not going to pay
for Xbox Live it will not happen no I
don't think but make I need to talk a
lot of and I honestly believe the only
barrier that Microsoft has in the next
coming generation is the pay to play as
far as Xbox Live if the PC allows you
not to do that um they're gonna remove
that barrier in some form of fashion
that barrier is gonna be removed that
way they've to roll it into game pass
you will not online and when we had
shout out the Lord Dan
colored ahead of xbox lava we had him in
on the realm you know we brought member
we challenged him and we said this is
one of the things that PC gamers look at
you know during this whole mark so
trying expanding like as a barrier like
why console games always saying why do I
have to pay when they do not and again
and I said he definitively said but he
cryptically kinda implied like there
will be possible changes in the future
but we obviously can't say anything at
this time they they're looking into that
so one would think like you said King
like if game pass is there you know and
this is the service that they're trying
to push to everyone you know it wouldn't
make sense if X cloud is gonna be their
driving force for them to kind of tack
on this double tax so to speak the
greatest month for game pass right act
and in a smaller history what's it like
12 to 16 games as we have arcane has
been amazing right now it's incredible
right now if you combine that with the
games for gold service this month is
insane mm-hmm
take away games for though naturally
remove that because there's no longer
necessary necessary it's redundant right
we can pass with all those games take
away the Xbox Live mm-hmm subscribe only
to game pass and all of those services
is built into that you know a remove
away that barrier so allow game chat
allow all of that but if you have game
pass then you have all of this stuff
extra to hold on hold I could make out a
chair he said Xbox you learn for but
then they should lock down their hard
drive until they solve back to finish
off you finish up your your boy and then
we get burnt now go ahead go raw finish
off after Bogut go bro which would you
think about all this may like the Triple
Threat matchup Tables Ladders chairs
discord once I'm saying and we got and
I'm saying steam our here is Amanda's
there's games releasing a Schlussel
beyond the storefronts now you know
let's talk about the elephant in the
room which is the next topic I mean
action that kind of broke the neck as
far as everyone thought it was gonna be
xbox play anyway right jazz was like I
got a refund ain't putting up with the
[ __ ] yeah like everybody was in a tizzy
I was upset I'm on PC now so that was
another game that I wanted to test to do
Xbox play anywhere and when I found out
on my epic store and then you hear about
the cut and you hear about exclusivity
and it is another game Hades right right
brother yeah yeah man what do you what
do you think about all this man it's
crazy but mmm let me ask my epic though
when they announced the the cuts on
their store right didn't they reimburse
developers in the past well they're
they're reimbursing developers for if
you're using immunity no all right then
real yet they basically they don't take
their cut of the the engine royalties
they don't take that okay that's
something one asked earlier mm-hmm so
what about probably it's changing
everything man steam better do something
cuz mmm so right now who do you feel is
the bigger threat to steam discord or
you feel the epic store
well fortnight kind of folds the nip is
gonna be a little screwed since they're
putting every egg into that basket mmm
it is interesting they both have some
different strengths like yeah what is so
huge right now but if it folds it sort
of holds everything and they throw away
effective tool they're gone they
sacrificed Unreal Tournament all just a
mere you know more money and time into
fortnight Ryan how long before I sustain
this phenomenal craze that is a good
point to but and we do realize though
haven't they pulled fortnight for mobile
devices they getting really stingy with
it like the I do you think they might be
planting something with their cuz I from
my understanding they pulled fortnight
of mobile stores correct another
important if any deployed trilogy yes
yes yes yes correct
fini blazer listen man this is
interesting and I'm about to jump in and
I'm like something bra finish up and
Ellie at each other
it's definitely changing the pc scene
I'm not the biggest PC gamer because I
have a laptop and it's not that powerful
mm-hmm but I feel you know what do you
think about all this adequate I think
this court is gonna be the thing that
that puts the nail in the coffin for
steam mmm I think discord - I think
people really sleeping although the only
big thing that I do see helping really
bad is they got an engine they're pretty
much giving you if you yes if you make a
game with the Unreal Engine and you put
it on epic like you're pretty much only
just you know you're not paying them
anything nearly a hundred percent of the
profit yes I think between them both
like and you know it's it's like I was
saying earlier like there are a couple
factors that's going to hurt all of them
the fact that II ain't going there the
fact that Ubisoft it's sooner or later
Ubisoft's gonna go exclusively on their
app because I'm no like all these big
publishers keep leaving Activision's
left they're doing stuff on battlenet
mm-hmm
so at the end of the day I don't think
Steam you know steams always gonna be
relevant but when all these big
publishers leave and they're getting
Indies like centers out on Steam right
now
Aston's not on Steam right now Hades is
it on Steam right now these are big
angel games they're getting the big
indie games the biggest publishers have
left right what what is steam gonna sell
after they've all left and here's the
thing the enticing these guys with that
cut you given these indie guys more
money more percentage and then they
literally throwing shots at who is it
that throw the shot they say yo ya
nobody don't need to be getting 30% of
the profit you know I'm saying I mean it
was on what you called discord discord
shot it was like yo nobody need when
they say 30 we said you know who they
coming for it's very the direct shot at
these guys at Steam so it's interested
and to me you got this court already has
that natural infrastructure when you got
nearly could I say shout at the world
ventureBeat oh my boy
Jeff Grubb he was like disco put another
dagger into the 77030 he said in this
store they will enable self-publishing
with a 90/10 display so they come in for
epic with that you're the then it's a
fortnight has 200 million players across
a lot of non PC platforms
this court has nearly 200 million of
chromos all on PC so Dave for and being
not a time on PC a lot more like discord
is the de-facto chat it's like almost
like an Xbox Live for them across all
scroll down to the relevant stuff oh my
god these guys are talking what imagine
here's what I see the future of discord
I think this course could be that
situation tour when all of these
platforms switch to an app and not a
console mm-hmm it's gonna be one of
those things where dis courts
integrating it into all of the apps
anyway
you go into the Super Smash Brothers and
it's like Oh everyone's playing Super
Smash Bros now it's an app so you just
click the button it goes straight to the
app you go straight into their log mmm
sounds Sammy press guy he said this cord
is way more of a threat Microsoft has
already has a relationship with this
cord it was true and Microsoft can get
their play any way into discord it's a
wrap no and did we did he have rumors
earlier members of them playing nice or
maybe Microsoft trying to acquire this
court at one point I'll finish up this
thing we move on them yeah I mean this
is crazy to me man like I was there in
King knows we were there day one for
steam when steam sucked but if you
wanted to play if you wanted to play
half-life 2
is all these publishers gonna leave
steam because obviously you know Ubisoft
might stick around you got your you know
BAM Namco and people that's what you
know discord and epic gonna fight over
is those third-party publishers that
don't have their own glassy yeah and
when you keep fight like you know right
now I would say you know it's between
epic steam and in this Court
but you know if Microsoft can say stuff
together they don't be a four-way battle
for all these all these things yeah the
good thing about Microsoft is they ever
get their foot you know words needs to
be today if they ever get their foot
where it needs to be on the Windows
market they already have relationships
with these companies to get these deal
yeah I what I end up seeing is I see
steam end up making games again and put
it on their platform already you know
yeah they said they were making games so
and this might force their hand have
more proactive with their you know
what's gonna happen I guarantee within
five years from today then is it even
gonna be relevant somebody will be out
there crying and then you get the
congratulations and I think that's the
biggest issue that we're having right
now is steam doesn't think that you know
what you know steam don't think they can
be dethroned they really haven't been
challenged yeah I think the most the
immediate threat is epic because of the
juggernut a fortnight yes immediately a
mediator Jackson but in the long term I
think is discord
I think weeks that they have which they
have their tentacles everywhere it's
just gonna be interesting man I try to
see them and discord is deployed maybe I
don't think fortnight's gonna drop off
completely you
I don't think it's not for long get that
minecraft filling where it's huge for
years and then it goes average and it's
X systems come out is gonna be something
that rivals day or night it's coming
straight to the next listen it's gonna
be it's a good fight it's a good fight
is good to see competition is always
good for the game a man so let's see
what happens so I'm just gonna do real
quick it's gonna be quick my bonus time
before we get a king um I got an ashen
rant and oh you know Lords when I'm done
me I need Lord addict to back me up on
this one cuz me we actually talked about
this before I'm nothing to say this but
I've grabbed you out the bushes so you
go do some shoutouts
so shout out the Lord Derek Bradley CEO
game director for action yeah we had the
pleasure meeting that pax please check
out the video on ILP channel this is way
before when Ashton was released and a
salute to our good friends at and a
prayer interactive know all respect
we're gonna pay respect and I want to
also saw shout out to Lord rend our
thoughts in the chat and now salty is
gaming they got to fantastic YouTube
reviews on ashen so look my main issue
here and this is my opinion this my rant
is that some of the media trying to act
like this coop is just this cool
artistic choice yes so easy to do and
it's just like when I watch an a pure
interactive have to come out there calms
manager has to come out and release an
ashen multiplayer FAC I think that's the
problem right so he goes you know for
everyone wondering you know how to do it
I put it back together and then he's
going into the whole you know okay so at
what point can we start playing with
other players
well first you need to run outside the
town boundaries in order
the worst King you can I have to remove
myself recuse myself from the
conversation because I have been paid
off from the company fraudulent any
nature because they accept me I would
take this sword thank you no I'll go but
I didn't play mold I played with the AI
and that that's a whole nother folk are
so so ashen what decides who I connect
with for two players to connect you know
they roughly need to be at the main part
of the story and you know if you gotta
make sure that you beat the same bossy
and keep in mind they're not telling you
how to do this in game and game and then
it says you seem area as another player
to run into a player I cool but all
Aisling like where can I not connect
defeat the other place and they talk
about the dungeons and all sort of stuff
now here's where it gets fun ashen how
can i connect with a specific player are
there two options to do this in the
multiplayer options you can disable
multiplayer to turn off all multiplayer
connections then use the multiplayer
filter which will all allow you to only
connect with someone after they give you
their multiplayer filter code to the
same number as yours using the multi
player filter code it's the best way to
connect with your friends so then they
ask for action what about PC and console
we don't support that because epic store
okay fine okay the last thing okay it's
just funny like do you know these
general tips of where to do it you gotta
be hmm it's worse than that
so you go through all of this you know
they give you the social security number
you you put it in its six six digits
let's say that you know I
okay Cognito we tried this one two three
four five six so we do that we go in
main kid actually had an incident last
night to where I guess someone else
that number hmm so it was linking me
with him it was leaking kid with him we
hopefully the lobby and change the
number no you can change it yourself
mm-hmm
that is not your cold because somebody
else could have said cold you have to
make your own number same no you got to
make it and then you got a pat you got
to call your man up and say oh here's my
social security if it's my beeper number
hit me and there is no guarantee and
then oh it gets worse so randomly
somebody in Australia can make the same
number better multi-player matchmaking
is in Ashton is region base so you'll
match players only in the region for
random encounters the same number that
you made let's say you know we finally
get you know we go through all this
nonsense you to find links up we go then
we fight the boss look I needed eyes he
is teasing we mean adding Miley got it
to work right we get into a dungeon
something happens to addict he fell off
the edge of something the game D sinks
him and I'm back with the AI companion
again then we got to go back to the
magical stone and all this other stuff
down outside the boundaries to try so
here's the funny part
so when we tried to resync right of a
day they definitely didn't Microsoft
published
they might have published the one on
xbox but I don't do they publish the
whole game itself all right all right
that is the most egregious to me right
besides the fact we have these weird
issues and all this stuff when you
finally get the Motown players work
because when action starts right you
create the way your man look there is a
custom character creator right so these
faceless keep done my choice no problem
but here's the issue with attic is in my
game he still looks like the AI guy
individual character really so there's
no way to know and again because I
pretty much have to tell them spin
around good way to tell if you're with
another player is if they use their
beacon or they run ahead of you instead
of the AI what I'm trying to the
industry this is an issue exactly so
again I'm bringing this to all the
reviews nothing and this isn't an it
this is not an issue again am i bugging
is this not a Calvin co-op situation and
it's not Calvin in the boardroom saying
Capcom got together he decided to give
them a tutorial they gave it to him but
they gave them have to do fly probably
have the fax machine
no I literally had to ask attic to do
all these wild game jumping's
am i bugging that and I think that this
is crazy that no one's going in on this
so I most of the reviews coming from
people who played it in cooperative
played it with the AI companion damn I
wish ran is still here please rant if
here because you have a review and you
said you've been playing it would go for
you gotta explain to me how y'all every
section of this game are able to link up
and you know it's him and if he died you
got to explain to me bruh cuz you had a
fantastic review I'm not trying to come
for you I'll just tell you me to know
that these developers they may have
built up such a great standing in a
community that no one is actually gonna
bash them even myself I got a nice
skateboard and myself is gonna be quite
don't lie thank you all were bought by
aura weren't they what kills me so this
game is beautiful like I only love the
yard so I am let me tell you why this
game is great but I I'm not even a dog
so that's good so it's like like I love
the yard style bro I think it's really
cool and in the selling point when I
spoke to Derek Bradley so all these
people saying that it wasn't designed it
was some path I spoke to the CEO slash
game directed like when when this thing
was at PAX I was like look man you got
me sold because once you say co-op
Cognito is in no I'm a sucker for that
co-op so I'm like oh
exactly so is seamless the game was
never marketed as a true coffee expert
even though they never came out openly
said those words if you look at every
trailer there's two people in it King
but even
ni is broken no like yes market is a to
co-op experience but you always you
never alone unless the game they've been
instances where I've been alone because
the game kind of broke and did he didn't
follow if you get killed an open area
chances are like he'll fight with you
he'll revive you if you go down if
you're anywhere near an enclosed area ad
or anything you're done running in place
at a door at the opening of a door
running in place and you get murdered
nope nope not coming for you not coming
for you not come until you by the moment
then the funny thing is the moment you
die before the screen goes black you see
him able to cross the threshold through
the door bribe a bug in here man am I
making this too much out of this help me
out bruh gameplay - yeah I got
downloaded on my xbox one thanks the
game pass no doubt gay bash man game
that year when we went to spire 73 facts
Dan was like guys have these free gift
cards I'm like what is this oh you're a
game pass bra yeah whoo
I've heard nothing about this though I
heard the game was great but I never
heard about the Jake yes dang I've heard
nothing about the janky-ass coop nothing
that's all no one's saying this is a bad
young no this is a single-player
experience you know with with uh with
the shaker of some bad multiplayer like
you know it's not bad but at the end of
the day like I feel like regardless what
people want to say they have done
nothing but market this as a coffee
experience I don't care what nobody say
me at date no one's gonna hear tell me
this game wasn't marketed as co-op a
king we would like is a perfect example
hmm we're playing this at events are
they not playing us in Paris thank you
it is we
clay P said he read way before people
before backs remember K we played at e3
then we played a pax and then we played
at maxi three and every time I played
the game
it got substantially better every time I
played it
um the last time I played the game and I
really sat down with it for at least 45
minutes to an hour and I came back and
he let me skip the line and everything
it was just a great experience um what I
can say from playing the game from that
only thing that I did play and I did not
play the multiplayer so I'm not gonna
have anything bad to say about it
his like I said from the pax build it
was way better at the e3 build III uh 18
built and the game looks so polished and
it looked exactly like was ready yet so
I don't know maybe I'm gonna give it a
chance but something I'm gonna get a
chance to play it don't you get the
chance man because it's hard at the
people in that game again the game is
great you know it's in-game past this is
not to destroy the rest of the game the
game is cool like it really is you don't
say but it just it blows my mind that
when I look at these reviews and no more
everyone's like this is a non-issue or
it's just art it's getting eight to nine
and I'm just like but Lord King man
let's get up out of here man
um you got some DLC talk about King this
is how you
King came back from selling boots and
goes that spider-man game is the real
deal you were high he was blown away by
his response I told him from seeing it
then that's gonna be game to you he was
like I'm sold to my dang dude have a
surprise my tree I was real surprised by
your response i pre-ordered it right
there I've done off the best game of the
show mm I thought and this DLC is very
intelligent and how they dropping it mmm
the last DLC is coming out on the 21st
I'm going to be playing it as soon as
I'm able to download it I'm going to
play it this is how a game of the year
is supposed to end the year my puttin
our constant content to keep you playing
the game throughout the year not playing
the same regurgitator stuff over and
over again just to get a different skin
but no drop in multiple suit you play
them storylines um but I'm getting
multiple suits I'm getting different
storylines I'm getting DLC but alright
what what point did you just make go
back to sleep alright I'm trying to
explain in my game of the year and
that's nice that you feel it your game
was and that's nice that one my game of
year debate year this year it's a
criminal offense when the DLC is coming
out and people are still talking about a
game that doesn't have anything else
coming out it's done that game is in the
bushes gone now let's talk about the
game that's coming out in the DLC coming
out and the people looking forward to
this DLC III specifically switch my
topic for this for PlayStation bro
because I know he enjoyed this game when
it came out and I want to hear his
thoughts on this go bruh mash you about
the other Raimi suit hey how about that
how you feel about that one gig that's
the baby I feel every suit in the game
and in unlocking them forcing you to
master these missions so you can get
these these orbs of coins every one of
them is tempered every student is
different
um that you have to get things a lot I
like your shoes without your shirt on
you can be in your underwear and it was
in a comic book all the stuff is stuff
from the comic books mmm they dictated
this is like a love letter to spider-man
fans oh yeah definitely most often
across the ages they going in on you on
this DLC slow-mo slow-mo once more than
two hours there two hours right
potentially perfect said he waited for
the complete edition then he next year
dr. B says body is a deadbeat daddy and
he wanted to step up for that situation
when she found that was a fraudulent
situation so sorry you can't say that
because you wanted to spin those webs
with the baby so sorry
but what game is doing it when you got
an actual game of the year
that the guy is teaching his kid bad
habit the whole game boy he said there
is no symbol I suit how can it be a love
letter to spotty fans with no Simba
yachts so hey did you not meet the game
wait how about exposing he came for me
with fallout 76 still in the butcher
actually got something to say with 76 is
half price right now when they give us
real bags and you given me
asked Ivan how many gave me you're 176
what anything bro you gotta get in man
let me talk about this what do you feel
about the silver lining man the city
that never sleeps
third DLC drop bra oh so stable coming
back come back
I can't believe let them steal my gear
like it was good to get nominated I
heard if you look past the game breaking
bugs and faults no sticks it gets pretty
good I heard that if you you know you
drop to seven six and you put three and
better game no I heard that after you
returned the game back you can actually
see the numbers of the actual sales of
the game in Reverse yes what do you
think about these three suits man bro
what'd you think about the three seats I
said de Armas outre me I don't care much
for the UM the spotter because it wasn't
a real game
have impressed guys that cyborg sir
decide I still had that cover spider-man
21 that issues seem a Deathwalker
standing there I was like so so into
that suit yes are you happy in general
with dealt with the release cadence or
the DLCs do you do you think this will
be the last one either day they might
not do any more stories at this room I
think they probably jumping on the
sequel the inevitable sequel gotcha I
could see more suits because I mean I
think they'll be kind of easier mm-hm I
would buy more out let me know a couple
bucks for no I know it's might be a
little hypocritical but the suits mean
that they come with powers too oh yeah
if anchorman news returning that game
will put talked out in his living room
he would have returned it this morning
last night the day before life leave a
colobus part of a DLC ever even I mean I
haven't played any of them so I haven't
really played since I finished the game
so but I'm off this week so I'm gonna
stop fraud anon that and play that go
back to read dead so stop frauding on
that he gone there's no doubt addict man
what about Spidey what you thinkin man
no because he my games you up on it
yes yeah I just I have no desire to play
I played the main game anything you just
want to speed one through the guy that
plays 10% of a game and think he's
actually did something
oh he got the fraud alert along with you
we already have the app we're gonna have
to start calling King the difficult
[Laughter]
looking right there you got it up - no
no I'm platinum both those games I'm out
of this conversation
hey King what suits you the most what
was the third suit inside the the Miss
World the one that gives you not not the
power one the one that gave you the
padding shoulders don't favor real quick
mm-hmm I think the curse one the cursed
one how your fraud ass don't have a
platinum
not one platinum
I don't play over there in the game
[Laughter]
alright cuz I think you're doing it like
this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
it regards the ashen play set up faq
released by the studio do you think
these steps are acceptable for
cooperative gaming in 2018 answers are a
yes clearly a design choice by the
developer adds a unique charm to the
game be know this antiquated state of
coop is unacceptable no more friend
codes or C I don't care yeah didn't keep
that same energy with monster hunter
world co-op system King
those are the choices please Rock the
aisle people when it goes up on Twitter
tomorrow Lord PlayStation absolutely
lesson to have you in the realm of the
Lord finally and what you got going on
sir you find me on Twitter every day all
day
alright at PlayStation brah really man
you know life's just been uh it's been
crazy
it's unfortunately I didn't cancel
you're lucky okay Friday night next
level gaming I was ready to go on there
yeah we're drooling into this pipe to
cut some a line into it mmm major leak
we have to shut this whole building down
a Tennessee state government building
ready to shut it down the water supply
to their units I was there till 11
o'clock that night then had to come back
home get up at 4:30 and go back and
finish the job at 6 a.m. wow I had to
cancel on Michael his show I had to
cancel on undead last week yeah I was
worried about you guys
I know no I was running behind early
because just getting my stuff set up it
bro I'm glad you able to make it man I
know you out there
Weldon want to construct the cons thank
you thank you for putting up with me and
thanks for having me on truly an honor
absolutely bro guys are a totally
different level thank you bro is a
pleasure to meet you in the flesh and
you know we're gonna do it again next
year man exactly 2019 again Pryor it's
family to the room so absolute pleasure
to have you in the movement I'm gonna
start some trouble because gaming Forte
says King got a trophy level of 8 and
attic as level 6 King wins I don't know
what's going on with receipts over there
so you gotta go see spider-man today
enemy I was seeing what katsu and I
forgot what happened plans didn't work
out because we Sony said early thing
brother yeah yeah yeah I'm supposed to
see it but is it really good everybody's
like it is it is legit it is the real
freaking deal son
that's the seller no doubt Lord Lord
addict back in the realm once again
being rambunctious got a gamer score
twenty six thousand nine that nothing
really is going into bushes alright okay
we can't wait to have you back at 1 p.m.
Lord solve finishing up the F strong
lord I am Bank wicked if I people find
you what you got going on sir okay you
guys can find me at Lord sob IOP on
Twitter and BX sovereign on PSN and xbox
live on big shout out to play station
Bravo coming to Ana last show of the
year man I hope to meet you at e3 next
year I know you guys had a ton of fun
last year's I hope to be be in the mix
this year um and it was real quick man a
message to everybody who who supports
and listens to the iron Lord podcast
like first of all to my brothers on the
podcast you know I love you guys
everybody everybody behind the scenes
the stream team mama my actual brother
katsu everything that everybody does to
make sure this podcast and everything
around it run smoothly thank you guys
amazing work
everybody that supports us on patreon
obviously weekend and week out we truly
appreciate it and last but absolutely
not least is everybody who listens to
the show every week and it's in the chat
every week you guys you make the show
like you really do make the show we make
it a point to interact with everything
that you guys throw out there because it
just makes it it makes it seem like
we're all in the room just talking
foolishness like we used to always and
this show would not be what it is
without you guys so we appreciate every
second of every day that you guys give
us time so one just want to say
absolutely it's been a great 2018-2019
is looking to be even better
thanks you guys everybody have a blessed
holiday whatever you celebrate and a
great new year and we'll see you in 2019
two weeks no Lord King mr. Witte
bumptious himself as well what is going
on with you wicked a palpable fire yes
what I would like to say first and
foremost to my brother Playstation bro
man there's a beautiful way to end the
year our last show with the bro
it was honor having you in the house I
can't wait to look forward to the next
year for you to come out there and have
another great time with us I mean we had
some really good times out there you
know and he got a lot of stories and a
lot of jokes and he's a real cool dude
genuine do vaccine but where you can
find me is putting lotion movies I'm put
them in a seat buddy self so you can
watch the film because they need to see
spider-man - y'all have a nice holiday a
great new year see on next year I
appreciate everybody for coming out and
having fun with us and addict nice
appreciate y'all too
yo yo we got betadine actually gonna be
late Nerys our attic is coming your
PlayStation Brett thank you again for
coming hey man long overdue no problem
bro you already notice my bro right here
we get it in cool gamer regardless of
what side of the fence we both on and
what we love we enjoy gaming that's what
it's about
we are at everybody podcast not just one
system we are in every got our
preferences but we are in everybody
podcasting like my brother Louis saw up
said man 2018 man very proud very proud
man just to see the support and
everybody coming through you know saying
the chat is always late we live off that
energy
it's been great man and we got big
bigger things planned but I want to
shout out like I said everybody who's
been a guest on ILP and 2018 salutes you
guys man man we've had some fantastic
grass industry guests regular guests big
small does not matter we always show you
love and we appreciate it back so thank
you on that you already know [ __ ] box
was gonna how to order you up later
tonight and all that time stamp stuff
will be going shout out to the stream
team you know I'm saying shout outs and
I'm doing anything snarled opt all that
stuff oh we've got the biggest day no oh
wow yeah we have an announcement so we
are proud to announce late our first
gleam giveaway going into the new year
ladies and gentlemen it is Kingdom
Hearts 3 this these copies legal right
it will be a digital copy of king of of
the NTSC you region one version of
Kingdom Hearts 3 for PlayStation 4 or
Xbox one you decide I'm not quite sure
on the end date for it but it is live
now so kaga if you guys can see the link
in the chat and I guess you will have it
in the show notes
we'll do that and yeah so to go out then
get that guy's yeah get that man we do
another one shut up
it's a shy boy who's a shout-out to mr.
leader giggle Oh as the back of the
truck version like I said we got a lot
stuff planned 2019 gonna be late
also I've you say you know gonna be more
combat talk flashpoint woody boxes is up
I think I got one more flashpoint for
the rest of the year and then I will be
done and then like I said everybody
enjoy your Christmas holiday your new
year that the tentative date is going to
be January 6th at 1:00 p.m. Eastern
that's when the Lord's will come back
everybody enjoy a new year anybody got
anything else left to say before we
close I enjoy you I do you a Happy New
Year Merry Christmas all that good stuff
peace